we turn uh right now to our guest in
studio well i'll stop talking about it
if he's not sitting here uh joining us
here live on the rich eisen show first
time i've i believe we've gotten a
chance to meet uh getting ready to enter
his 11th season in the national football
league one of the many lsu tigers in the
nfl now with the detroit lions michael
brockers good to see you here man thanks
for having me thanks for having me
thanks for coming on this program all
right so
it's very rare that i've got a real uh
live bona fide veteran nfl player
sitting in the seat as a major rule
change in the nfl has just been approved
by
league uh membership so um both teams
now required to touch the football
in overtime do you like that michael
brockers i think i do i think i do um i
think i don't think it has anything to
do with you know not has anything to do
with but it doesn't do anything for the
bills uh this year
i know i know they got it changed it
might might have you know work for him
in the future but i mean for me i like
it i like it you know both teams get to
have their offense especially in a
situation like that you get high
explosive offenses they just go back and
forth that's what the fans love to see
so i guess i'm mandated to ask you this
question then it's in your now 10 full
years in the nfl entering your 11th have
you ever been involved in a game
where it went to overtime
and you didn't your team didn't get a
chance to to
win the game after the other team scored
a touchdown first it just ended or even
a field goal back in the day has that
ever happened to you
i've
i've tied twice in my career so that's
crazy i've tied twice so
i've been through that moment you leave
the game and it's like that's it limbo
yeah you feel like you're in limbo
you're like we didn't lose
but we didn't win as well so it's a it's
it's weird it's a weird feeling so
that's a tie but you've never been in a
situation where
you know
you're you're out so i guess the
situation would be you'd be the one out
there on the field
and then your offense would be just like
okay i guess we don't get a chance today
right that's never happening never i
don't think it happened
i don't i don't remember i don't
remember i know i've been been a part of
two times i just don't remember when we
went into overtime a couple you know
this is like my rookie year and we're
going against san fran and i just i just
remember us losing uh not losing but we
didn't make the field goal to win the
game
but i don't i don't recall who had the
ball first who would not but see the the
issue i have with this new
construct in overtime michael brockers
of the lions here in the in studio on
the rich eisen show is now the team that
gets it second right
i think you're going to want the ball
second in overtime now you win the toss
wouldn't you want to know again you
played defense so i guess this is you're
on the other side of the
coin for the lack of better phrase here
but you know wouldn't you want your team
to go second
because you'd want to know
offensively what you have to do in order
to win i mean i think that gives you a
little bit of advantage especially if
you see the other team go for one point
instead of two or goes for that you know
they go for two now you have to go for
two i think you know going second gives
you a little bit of an advantage
especially if you see the other team and
what they do first what about
defensively what would you as a
defensive player want to do get get out
there first
and let your team know what you have to
what they have to do and keep it to zero
or three obviously not seven even worse
eight
right or would you wanna know
you know what your offense is already
done and what you have to do defensively
how would that change do you think
defensively the approach of
overtime now that you say that is weird
because now i'm thinking like okay
i get on the field first now i put
myself in that scenario i get on the
field first and um
we stop them
you know usually you feel like okay
that's it you know we kick a field goal
it's over
and now it's like okay
they we go first they score
we now we have to go back you know if
they go for one if they go for two right
now we have to go back and the offense
has to go down and then you think about
okay they go down the score
we have to do this all over again like
does it stop
no then it would be then it would then
it would be old-fashioned okay okay
okay right but i'm just because i think
we're onto something here because this
is fascinating to me because if you're
def if you're a part of the defense that
goes second right okay so your your team
let's just say your team offensively
let's say jared goff and the lions get
the ball first
and score a touchdown yeah now you as a
lion's defender michael brockers would
be going against the team that's to
screw it fourth down doesn't matter for
my own eight my own 18 where we have to
go right so i would imagine that would
you'd be playing four downs every single
moving of the change if that happens
exactly that's what i would think you
know it's four down territory all the
way down the field because they know
they have to score they don't
score if they don't move the chains
there's they lose the game is that
better for you do you think what do you
think um
now i understand you're a player and you
just got to play it i don't know that's
what they think within his own box but
because that changes so much for you i'd
imagine
if you're defending that situation
i'm thinking about what are we calling
are we calling pressures are we calling
just defense you know let everything
happen in front of you what are we doing
you know because i'm like i'd rather
pressure get it out the quarterback
hands fast let us rally to the ball
stuff like that
but in a situation where you're like
it's do or die you don't want to you
don't want to pressure and give up a big
play and now you know you have to redo
that that whole scenario over again so i
don't know that's weird you know what i
mean it would be going against a team
that just uh on offense that has
no tomorrow right they're living for the
moment every single down
as opposed to if you're the defense that
goes first you know you're going against
the team that might have to hedge their
bets a little bit on the fourth down and
you know in no man's land and things
like that
that's one thing you don't want to go
get somebody backed into a wall
you know they got to fight their way out
so it's like
you don't know what to expect you know
they can
the the book is hoping for you know well
i guess michael brockers this would be a
high class problem a half since it's in
the playoffs you take that you take just
you take making the playoffs right off
the bat so let's talk about the lions
here a little bit with you
um on on a scale of
one to dan campbell how crazy is your
coach
that's funny uh he's dan campbell he's
all the way there he hits it and
surpasses it
yes he is he is he is and that's him on
a daily that's him in in our in like
pre-game speeches
you know at after practices that's him
all the time well because the one thing
that i noticed right from the get-go
uh when you started playing
is that the team never
gave up
never right never gave up and you know
those december games for a team that's
not making the playoffs dion sanders
taught me a long time ago and marshall
faulk and all the other hall of famers
i've been so fortunate to be around as a
broadcaster we call them u-haul games
where the u-haul's backed up you know
everybody's got and the last thing
anybody wants to do is be rehabbing an
injury in january when december games do
not matter
but i did not see that
at all for the lions this past year why
why do you think we enjoy playing for
him we enjoy playing for him he's he's
he's the
iconic players coach he was a player so
he understands what we go through uh
mentally physically throughout the year
um so he understands man that sometimes
you know your body's gonna hurt you know
let me give these guys a little break
you know
um
with in his situation we're such a young
team so he has to play that you know
play that fence kind of you know
he has to work it a little bit but you
know for the most part the guy has
understand that he's he's looking out
for um their best benefit and you know
when when you have a guy that looks out
for you you want to look out for him so
going all out that's one thing that's
what we're about you weren't on the team
yet when he was hired though right did
that where you were
i mean i was a part of like the whole
new revamp you know the team so when he
got hired i was
soon to be hired after that that's right
that's what i was about to ask about you
know how
you might have taken in his opening
foray press conference about biting
kneecaps and right things like that it
was it was it was a little you know out
there but i i got what he meant you know
i got and that's what you've seen from
us this year is like we're not gonna
give up we don't care who you are we
understand that we are the detroit lions
and everybody has a stigma about us but
we're changing and we're coming for you
and i love his his whole statement about
welcome to detroit because that's what
we're all about we have uh hard knocks
here this year so like i'm excited this
is my third time doing it and um i just
want i just this is a good time to show
the the people the fans around the world
what we what we're about it's not all
about you know um
you know the x's and those man you get
to see a lot of these coaches on this
coaching staff that have played in this
this game we also you know aaron glenn
you know he's a phenomenal cornerback in
the league yes he's our defensive
coordinator you know he has a lot of
things that we do old school type thing
up downs we'll be doing up downs and
training camps stuff like that so um
you'll see a lot of that uh from our
staff and i'm excited for them so how
how
how what would you tell your your
teammates about
the hard knocks that's coming see the
hard knocks like don't try to be don't
try to
you know build a character don't try to
you know make yourself a character for
hard knocks hard knocks is here to
observe what we're doing it's not about
you you know you're you being a
character and you know everybody knows
your name now like they're here to
observe what we do how we work how we go
to buy a business um so the biggest
thing is about uh just be yourself be
yourself go about work as a professional
like you do every day um
just be you that's the biggest thing
don't don't change because the cameras
are around they're going to be in your
face they're going to be around the
the crew is going to be a little
annoying because they have wires all
over the place there you know that
sometimes you got to tell them to move
out the way because they they want to
get every every shot you know the best
angle so sometimes you have to tell them
hey excuse me you know watch out we
about to work so um you know just be you
this question may run counter to what
you've just said michael brocker
my apology in advance um who do you
who do you think is going to be though
the hard knocks
star that we don't know of yet
for the detroit lions just merely by
being themselves i'm not saying you're
going to counsel them
to use this as an opportunity to brand
themselves or branding you know even
though as you you've just said
you know
some players your your teammates might
go in that direction right
who's that guy you got a prediction for
me no it's going to be easy it could be
a coach too could be it could be a
trainer you know what if i had anybody
that wanted to to build
a character around or build you know a
story around it'd be it'd be deuce it'd
be deuce uh running backs coach um he's
uh he was a phenomenal player in this
canister uh is it no stanley park
david um
but he was a phenomenal player yes but
he brings this this intensity
where he's always on 10. he's always
like in your face smashed mouth like
he's always like that you know and it's
subtle but it's like
you understand he's always at this level
every day like it can be eight o'clock
in the morning he's like what's up you
know like
come on coach like
bring the energy down man like but
he's a he's a phenomenal coach i love
him i mean he's he he brings energy
every day now that's what uh that's what
i like about it i love energy i'm an
energy guy i love it at practice and you
know one one thing i can count on if i
if i talk a little little crap he's
going to say something too so
is that right oh yeah practice oh oh
yeah we're talking that's what that's
why i'm excited for hard knocks like we
are talking a.g
is talking to dudes you know dan might
be the most quietest person get out here
no no he doesn't talk during practice
like he wants it to run run
run well but for the most part like he
lets dudes a.g we talk they talk i don't
know
that's what they there is
dudes
that's him
all day all day it's like he's angry all
the time but i don't want to say he's
angry he's just like he's intense he's
intense he's intense please tell me
they're not serving coffee in the
coaches room because it sounds like
they're already highly connected i think
it's mountain dew i think it's mountain
dew and vince
venti uh
espresso whatever
whatever coach campbell has that's what
that's what they're having in the break
room all right so how good can the lions
be you're hearing about you look you you
hear stuff you're a man of the of the
world you're a veteran in this league
you know the talk that you know of
course aaron rodgers is coming back it's
the nfc north right right why would he
leave right and you hear about the lines
and all of that business so what do you
think how good can you speak
i'm gonna tell you this let me tell you
this this is this is what i like about
this scene we're scrappy we're scrappy
we're here um we finished we finished
well last year we finished really well
last year i'm excited to see what this
team brings next year um you know a lot
of us you know me
uh personally you i'm more comfortable
around the team i feel like i can be a
little bit more vocal i know a little
you know know more of the guys stuff
like that so uh for me i feel like we're
gonna do well um i don't want to put any
expectations on us anything like that i
know we will do well because uh you know
we have the right guys right core the
right leaders um that's going to push
this team to go past what we're you know
what everybody expects us to do okay
before i let you go let's talk about you
you're 11 that's no joke right you may i
mean
uh when
when you come out uh of college i mean
that's you're on average you're four and
right you're you're closing in on 3x of
that which is impressive that's crazy
it's a blessing and i'm just looking at
your hat you got what is that don't get
ready stay ready yeah this is kind of
like my motto my my brand my motto kind
of you know like you said 10 year 10
going into year 11. yeah um i can see
the light you know i can see
i can see that little glimmer of light
at the end of the tunnel so uh for me
it's just you know kind of setting
myself up
um you know outside of football you know
once you once you know this game is over
for me nobody's gonna care who i am so
what you're saying
that's kind of usually how it goes if
you're not like a hall of famer that you
know that your name that's
you know everybody knows you kind of
just fall off and just kind of going you
know off into the sunlight hold on a
second now i want to push back on that a
little bit what i mean i no no i
understand that right just let's just
throw some names out here okay what
about nate burleson does that sound like
him
no but he's
you could say he's an outlier in a way
so you have that you have that
opportunity for yourself yeah that's
what you're talking about
that's what i'm talking about setting
myself up but i definitely want to be
you know want to be
uh you know seen i plan on starting my
podcast i'm a little nervous about what
about just you know
people wanted to hear what i have to say
i i'm nervous about that for some reason
because i feel
you know i'm little old me you know i i
you know i think very humbly of myself
okay so uh maybe two maybe too much so
maybe too much i mean there's an eye in
michael right come on now true true
maybe that could be your the name of
your podcast there's an eye on michael
um see i'm about to this is res
consulting right tj is it that's what we
got here
hold on a second oh charlie seriously
charge
i appreciate that absolutely and plus
it's it's not live so if you don't like
what you say just start again right
record it again yeah
no for real
yeah
i appreciate that simple seriously like
this is live like we can't go back right
like that s bomb you just said moments
ago yeah i didn't mean it
sorry kids
actually i'll be honest i take that in a
way like you know we're having just a
regular conversation but i felt
comfortable enough to the curse well you
know but that's i don't know if uh radio
fights
no but
so so if that's what you want to do like
now's the time to start it you know it's
true exactly to have your teammates on
and
and um you know i think there's a
a player uh media summit that's coming
up here in los angeles in a couple of
weeks yeah that so
and if there's anything i could do to
help and i appreciate that i truly do
because this is uh it's a little
nerve-wracking when you go off on your
own and you kind of sure you're
separating yourself from from the league
it's easy when you know you're a
football player and everything's coming
easy but you kind of separate yourself
off and brand off on your own you kind
of almost feel like you're on the island
a little bit okay but it's all about
networking so i appreciate your course
man
so you wanted like the paparazzi that's
your no not the paparazzi made more like
nate you know be seen i've seen they
don't i think i seen him on cnn the
other day he's on cbs this morning cbs
or cnn i was like okay he's talking
about world events yeah world events and
he i looked i looked up to him
and nate would come on nfl total access
when i was hosting it back in the day
and he was on detroit and um and he
would he just worked at it and now look
at him now look at that number some
practice man somebody practicing great
people in your corner well uh i'm i hope
to be one of them and i appreciate you
coming on this this opportunity is
available to you anytime you want yes
sir thank you i'm right around the
corner so excellent we'll have you on
there and uh maybe you'll be our our
like our hard knocks correspondent come
on let me let me let me wait there we go
you can send us you know like behind the
scenes videos michael just dm to the
show yeah yeah yeah no no we don't need
dms again hold on a second let me let me
let me let me let me teach you let me
let me let me let me just teach you
something about this business
tj part of the reason why we would want
michael to do this it's not just because
we you know enjoy your company as we
just have over the last 20 minutes
but if it's not dm'd and you do it you
know call in or whatever cameras are
following you then this show winds up on
hard knocks through you
so this is us branding through you
that's part of the business is to come
across as seeming like you know hey
we're all friends but it's really about
me right right i mean there's a lot of
people like this in this business you
get that i'm just trying to
scratch over this right now is a hard
knock lesson right in media as we send
you out into right
i appreciate that thank you so much
don't wind up on hbo that's a good point
that's a good thing what i'm saying we
need to give him some swag get him a cup
spell us you want a mug
hold on nfl films hold on a second get
this
hold up
yeah right oh yeah
then like a cup of joe in the morning
right
dan campbell drinks 80 ounces of coffee
a day really right in that moment not
the only member that coaches
thanks for the call uh thanks for
actually stopping by here and thanks for
the call in advance anytime michael
brock thanks for having me you're 11.
going into the nfl year 11. michael
brock is here live on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here